if there's one thing that movie fans
everywhere seem to be able to agree on
its that Keanu Reeves is a pretty
awesome guy but although his career is
going great nowadays Reeves once spent
over a decade blacklisted by one of
Hollywood's biggest studios so just why
was he thrown into movie Jail for eleven
long years before you can really
understand why Keanu Reeves spent so
long out in the wilderness you first got
to understand the events leading up to
his exile and for that you've got to
start at the beginning of his career
after featuring opposite Rob Lowe in a
forgettable yet strangely successful
hockey movie called Youngblood Reeves
caught the world's attention with
river's edge a controversial movie about
a pathetic teens in the killing of a
young girl soon Reeves was showing up in
way bigger films such as Dangerous
Liaisons which starred the likes of John
Malkovich Glenn Close uma Thurman and
Michelle Pfeiffer then of course he was
cast as one of his most iconic
characters the laid-back time-traveling
wannabe rock star Theodore Logan of Bill
& Ted's Excellent Adventure from there
he went on to prove his action skills by
catching waves and busting bank robbers
in Point Break granted Reeves also made
a couple of missteps early in his career
for example he proved to the world he's
incapable of doing an English accent
with back-to-back performances in Bram
Stoker's Dracula and much ado about
nothing but by this point Reeves his
career was speeding forward nonetheless
and the actor was about to make a huge
leap from up-and-comer to blockbuster
King the year 1994 was pretty phenomenal
for film in general with the release of
classics like Pulp Fiction the Shawshank
Redemption The Lion King and Forrest
Gump Plus adrenaline junkies got their
fix with a whole slate of awesome action
flicks such as The Crow True Lies Leon
the professional and of course the movie
that made Keanu Reeves a bona fide star
speed directed by yonder Bond speed
follows Jack Travon a police officer who
finds himself up against a psychopathic
terrorist who's rigged a bus to explode
if it drops below 50 miles per hour
along with courageous commuter Annie
Porter Travon has to defuse the bomb
catch the bad guy and save the day
really speed is everything you could
possibly want from an action
Reeves and Bullock have a whole lot of
sizzling chemistry the leading man did
most of his own stunts and yeah they
really jumped that bus as a result the
movie impressed critics turned Reeves
and Bullock into a-listers and earned
350 million dollars against a 38 million
dollar budget
unfortunately there's always a dark side
to success and speeds box-office victory
was about to send Keanu Reeves to the
cinematic slammer
when a movie enjoys as much box-office
success as speed did what happens next
is pretty much inevitable and sure
enough the very week the money started
pouring in from speed Fox gave the
go-ahead for part two as a result
director Yan de Bont started reading new
scripts and sounding out potential ways
for the story to go inspired by a
recurring nightmare in which a cruise
ship crashed into an island de Bont
decided to set his sequel at sea the
movie would start off with Jack Travon
and Annie Porter as a married couple
with the two going on a tropical cruise
that is rocked by a major terror attack
courtesy of a vengeful hacker who is
fired by the cruise line of course if
you're going to make a speed sequel
you've got to bring back your original
stars Bullock signed the dotted line
after Fox promised to finance hope
floats a romantic drama directed by
Forest Whitaker in which Bullock plays a
spurned housewife trying to take charge
of her life but if you switch on speed
to cruise control these days you might
notice that Keanu Reeves is nowhere to
be found
instead Jason Patric is playing some new
cop named Alex Shaw so what's up with
the switcheroo
why did Reeves say no to speed -
obviously Fox wasn't happy when their
star abandon ship in the movie studio
immediately started spreading propaganda
about him saying he was off touring with
his rock band dog star instead of making
movies according to Reeves however that
couldn't be further from the truth
there were several reasons why he didn't
want to square off against Willem
Dafoe's bug-eyed terrorists but playing
the bass wasn't one of them so what did
prevent Reeves from signing on to the
sequel
well first off he was all actioned out
Reeves had just finished filming on
chain-reaction a thriller starring
Morgan Freeman and Rachel Weisz the
movie has Reeves starring as a scientist
who invents a new power source only to
find himself framed for murder and on
the run when the FBI comes calling
critics weren't crazy about the action
flick and the
was Rives he described the process of
making the movie as really unsatisfying
lamenting the fact that he had to do so
much running in action all in all it was
a disappointing experience for reads the
experience left him exhausted and
unwilling to make speed - so soon after
working on another action movie on top
of all that the star had also recently
broken his ankle in a motorcycle
accident so doing all the stunts that
would be required of him for cruise
control probably didn't sound like much
fun before casting Jason Patric as the
lead in speed - Fox offered Keanu Reeves
a hefty paycheck of 11 million dollars
to reprise the role of jack Travon but
Reeves turned him down not just because
he was tired of action films but also
because he had his eye on new more
exciting projects Reeves was
particularly interested in playing the
lead role in the Satanic legal thriller
The Devil's Advocate this movie finds
Reeves playing a hotshot lawyer from
Florida who's invited to join a
successful Manhattan law firm when he
shows up in the Big Apple
he meets his new boss a devilish wheeler
and dealer named John Milton who seduces
Reeves his character into a life of sin
both in and out of the courtroom the
devil's advocate was filming at the same
time as speed to cruise control but in
Reeves his mind it was a pretty simple
choice between the two he could act
across from Al Pacino and scream at
Satan in a penthouse suite or he could
get soaking wet doing aquatic stunts all
day long obviously the choice was easy
better to rule in Hell than swim and
speed - at the end of the day however
there's one reason above all that kept
Reeves away from cruise control he
thought the movie script absolutely
sucked in 2015 Reeves went on Jimmy
Kimmel Live to promote an upcoming film
and the talk-show host asked just why
Reeves wasn't on that cruise ship with
poor Sandra Bullock Reeves answered
honestly it was just a situation in life
where I got the script and I read the
script and I was like ah of course
trash-talking speed too wasn't a new
look for Reeves as far back as 1997 he
was telling the Toronto Star that the
script wasn't great so Reeves bowed out
and let the speed sequel sail on by and
as it turns out he wasn't the only one
who thought cruise control was a really
bad idea according to many speed - is
the worst thing that's happened to
cruise ships since the Titanic plowed
into that iceberg hoping to recreate the
success of the
original movie Fox executives gave
director Yan dibond a budget of 100
million dollars for speed too but de
bont speed too still went over-budget
with some suggesting the movie cost a
whopping 165 million dollars to make the
studio poured a near endless amount of
cash into the high-octane sequel but
nobody wanted a Part two without their
lovable leading man
so speed to bombed hard the movie made
160 4.5 million at the box office which
is exactly what you don't want to happen
when you've just made a movie with a
budget of 165 million dollars on top of
that The Critic circled speed to
shipwreck like sharks and wasted no time
in tearing it to pieces over on Rotten
Tomatoes the movie has a shockingly low
approval rating of just 4 percent with
speed 2 sinking in theaters it was
suddenly crystal clear that Keanu Reeves
made the right decision by staying far
away from the doomed sequel but he
wasn't to escape the disaster without a
scratch in the wake of speed twos
disaster release 20th Century Fox
apparently decided it was time to
blacklist Keanu Reeves speaking with GQ
in 2019 the actor claimed that the
company tossed him into what he called
movie Jail banning him from starring in
any of their movies as retribution for
turning down cruise control Reeves spent
11 years on Fox's bad side and during
that time the studio released some
pretty high-profile films such as x-men
The Phantom Menace and Minority Report
and you can't help but wonder how
different Reeves his career might look
if the studio had considered him for any
one of those projects sadly Fox didn't
shine its spotlights his way until 2008
when Reeves played an environmentally
conscious alien in The Day the Earth
Stood Still and while he's not in the
cinematic slammer anymore Reeves still
doesn't do that many studio films these
days the last time he worked with one of
the big companies for a live-action
leading man role was 47 Ronin with
Universal Pictures and since then he's
taken to showing up in smaller fare like
the bad batch and the neon demon even
the John wick movies are relatively
low-budget Affairs distributed by the
independent production company Lionsgate
while we'll never know what movies
Reeves could have starred in have he
remained in Fox's good graces the good
news is that the actors career wasn't
damaged too badly by the whole speed to
Fiasco just because Fox didn't want to
work with Keanu Reeves didn't mean the
other stood
wouldn't either after all he was a hot
young actor with a whole lot of promise
and in 1999 Reeves teamed up with Warner
Brothers for a weird little sci-fi flick
called The Matrix with its epic gun
battles leather outfits and fascinating
philosophical beliefs the movie landed
with the impact of a well-placed kung-fu
punch and everybody started paying
serious attention to the man they called
neo the matrix revolutionized science
fiction gave birth to two sequels and
continues to influence pop culture to
this day in other words Keanu Reeves was
doing just fine without Fox ensure there
was a period post matrix where Reeves
wandered in the wilderness making a slew
of subpar films like The Watcher the
lake house and Street kings but the guy
was also making some interesting choices
too with perkier projects like
Constantine and A Scanner Darkly of
course the Keanu Reeves Renaissance
really began when a group of Russian
gangsters broke into his home killed his
puppy and stole his car people keep
asking if I'm back and I haven't really
had an answer but now yeah I'm taking on
back John wick was a sleeper hit that
spawned a franchise full of incredible
fight choreography amazing world
building and some of Keanu Reeves
greatest moments as an actor
today he's bigger than he's ever been
popping up in huge movies such as Toy
Story for making hilarious cameos and
quirky comedies showing up at
conventions and receiving all kinds of
adoration on the Internet all that and
he never did have to do speed - could've
been worse
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one